PAUL SAXMAN: Hello everybody,
my name is Paul Saxman.
Thanks for tuning in.
I'm a Senior Developer Advocate
at Google, and today
I'm going to answer a few
questions that we had on
Moderator about building Android
apps for Google TV.
Next week we're going
to be talking--
we have a track at Google I/O.
We're going to be covering a
few different topics.
One is actually UI.
One is integrating media
devices with Google TV.
And one is on the second screen
I'll specifically be
giving the second screen talk.
So today, I'd like to cover a
few of the questions that we
had on second screen
applications.
But I'd also like to cover a
few of the other general
questions that you had, because
we had a few really
good ones via Google
Moderator.
And we have some in Stack
Overflow that we'll talk about
today as well.
On Google Moderator we had
a really good question.
It actually ends up being
a few questions
wrapped into one.
The question is, I want to send
my Google, or Facebook ID
password, to Google TV
for my Android phone.
How can I connect or sync
between devices?
I'm saying that's kind of
two questions in one.
Primarily because managing IDs
and passwords is really one
separate topic beyond actually
syncing data between devices.
So I'd like to cover that
separately from
actually the syncing.
It's very fortuitous that
there's a few questions about
syncing data between devices,
because, like I said, that's
the talk I'm giving next week.
So I can maybe give you a little
bit of a preview about
some of the content that
I'm going to have.
So in terms of connecting or
syncing between devices you
actually have a number
of different options.
The main option is really
do it yourself.
You can actually use the
Java.net libraries which are
available on the Android
framework.
These actually let you
bring up a server
socket on Google TV.
You instantiate a socket on your
Android phone, and you
actually can just do raw socket
communication between
the two devices.
The easiest way to actually find
the Google TV device, on
the home network, for example,
is to use MDNS.
Google TV devices actually
broadcast an MDNS service
called Anymote on the
local network.
So if you use an MDNS library
you can scan the network.
Find the IP address of the
Google TV device in the living
room or in the user's
home network.
Once you have the IP address,
you can actually open up the
socket connection and do the
communication yourself.
We've found, actually, that
building up that type of
communication, like the socket
communication, there's a lot
of stuff that's repeated
or a lot of apps
that actually share.
So we're actually looking to
put together a library that
developers can use to help
automate some of that.
So your second option is to use
a library that we'll be
discussing in a little more
detail at Google I/O.
Your third option for sharing
data between two devices, or
Google TV device and a handheld
device, is actually
using the Anymote library.
The Anymote library is a little
bit different from just
raw data communication though.
It's actually more of a remote
control library that allows
handheld devices to send events,
like key events and
mouse events, from a handheld
device to the TV.
And the interesting thing about
Anymote is that actually
the TV, or whatever app is in
the foreground on the TV
actually, receives
those events.
So you can actually use a
handheld device as an input
device to send key
and mouse events.
So that actually doesn't really
fit into the question.
So what I'd say here is that
for syncing data, just raw
data, either you're going to
look at opening up socket
connections.
You can use the MDNS
to discover the
devices on the network.
Or maybe wait a few days, or a
week, and see what we have for
the library for sharing data.
In terms of actually IDs and
passwords, and how you want to
manage IDs and passwords on
devices, the short answer is
you probably don't.
You probably want to rely on
something like the Android
Account Manager to manage
your Google accounts.
Because when a user actually
sets up an Android device they
enter their username
and password.
And then those credentials are
actually used to get access to
Google services.
I don't exactly remember the
details, but it might be
possible to actually get some
kind of authentication token
out from the Account Manager
that you can
share with Google TV.
Or you can actually rely on
Google TV itself to actually
have the credentials.
It also has the Account Manager
so you can rely on
that as well.
Like any other Android device,
the user actually enters their
credentials when they
set up the device.
As far as Facebook is concerned,
I'm not too
familiar with how
their APIs work.
What I have seen on some
applications is that it
actually opens up a web
interface when the user
authenticates the Facebook
service.
And I mean generally how this
type of authentication works
is the application developer
doesn't have access to the
credentials.
But they will have access to
some kind of token that they
can use for authentication
to the service.
So likewise, in that situation,
if you do get a
token back from their APIs you
can actually send it to the
Google TV device using raw
socket connections.
Let's see, another
question we have.
So this is actually a very
popular question not only in
Moderator, but we get this
question a lot about Anymote
and developing second
screen apps and what
libraries are available.
Like I said, we're actually
going to release more
libraries around Google
I/O next week.
So stay tuned for that.
What we have right now, however,
we have quite a few
libraries available.
We have the Anymote library,
like I mentioned earlier.
That's a protocol for actually
sending key events and mouse
events from a handheld
device to Google TV.
And it actually is a very
sophisticated library, because
it actually secures all
the communication.
And the reason you want
to do that, secure the
communication, is that if you
are entering key codes in a
handheld device or using the
handheld device as a keyboard
or using the key input, the user
could be entering things
like passwords and login.
You don't want necessarily
send that
clear text to the TV.
So the library actually secures
the data interchange
so that it can't be sniffed
on a local network.
So the Anymote protocol, the
Anymote library, is actually
available in Java for Android
devices or for Java
applications or Android
applications.
We also very recently released
the C++ version.
The C++ version we didn't
provide these wrappers, but
could be used for iOS
devices as well.
If you are building an iOS
application, and you want that
to integrate with Google TV, you
can look into that as an
option as well.
We also have the Android remote
control for Google TV.
We open sourced that.
And so if you want to build a
remote control application,
much like the Google TV remote
for Android, you can actually
start there as well.
Also very recently, we released
a library called the
Anymote library.
To be slightly differentiated
from the Anymote Protocol
library that we released
previously.
The Anymote library is actually
an Android library
that you can import into an
Android project and Eclipse,
and use it from there.
It actually simplifies the
communication with Anymote.
Actually, the pairing,
discovering, communication
with Anymote quite a bit.
So if you are thinking about
building an application, you
might want to look into this
Anymote library as well.
I've implemented an app
using this library.
It's a matter of 100 to
200 lines of code.
If you implemented the Android
remote control, or the Google
TV remote control for Android,
if you take a look at that
code it's quite a bit
more sophisticated.
There's a lot more code that
was pushed up to the client
side there.
Whatever code we could abstract,
and put in this
Android library, we did.
So those are a few
of the options.
We're probably going to, like
I said, talk about some more
stuff at Google I/O about second
screen applications and
code that's available.
So my shameless pitch right now
is that if you're really
curious about second screen
applications, and building
them, be sure to check
out our talk at I/O.
So I'm going to move on.
So we get a lot of questions
about finding out what TV show
or movie, a Google TV
user is watching.
Of course a lot of developers
are really interested in this,
because then you can do things
like tailored ads.
You can tie into social
streams and actually
synchronize the viewing
experience with a data feed or
a social stream.
Unfortunately, we don't
support that
presently on Google TV.
The issue is, A, it's actually
a secure video path.
We can't just expose the
secure video path to
applications for them to
analyze it themselves.
The other issue is that--
so even though the Google TV
remote controls are universal
remotes, the user actually uses
that to replace any other
remote that they have in
their living room.
And the way that works is Google
TV devices presently
have infrared blasters.
So when you configure your
Google TV device you say what
other AV devices and set-top
boxes you have
in your living room.
And then it can be configured to
control those applications
through the Google TV
remote control.
The issue is though-- so if a
user uses the Google TV remote
control we know, essentially,
what they've changed their
channel to.
However there's no guarantee
that the user
used the remote control.
They could use their set-top
box remote control.
They could use any other.
Go to the TV and change
the channel directly.
There's a number of different
things they can do.
We don't have that information
necessarily.
So we don't presently have an
API for actually exposing what
channel the user is currently
watching.
But this is a pretty common
request we get from
developers.
We are definitely investigating
other ways that
we could potentially
solve this problem.
Another very, very common
question we get is about
embedding live TV
in applications.
What a lot of developers want
to do is, in addition to
actually synchronizing let's say
information and live TV,
they want to put that in a
single interface on the TV.
So, for example, you could be
watching a sporting event and
maybe on the right hand side
you can actually see live
statistics.
Embedding live TV in an
application is something that
we currently don't support.
We absolutely get this
request a lot.
We think it's a very,
very valid use case.
And we are absolutely looking
at ways to solve
that problem as well.
We don't have anything to
announce in the very near
term, but, like I said, along
with knowing what the user is
watching, embedding live TV
is something that we're
definitely listening
to developers on.
We have another question
about Anymote.
This is from a developer
that's very
familiar with Anymote.
And the question is, will
Anymote support international
languages for upcoming
deployments in other countries?
We have made announcements that
Google TV is actually
coming to other countries
sometime this year.
Stay tuned on what countries
and when.
So we are looking into actually
adding that support
to Anymote right now.
We think we have a potential
solution.
I'd say stay tuned on that.
It's something that we have
a solution in hand.
It's just a matter of getting it
in the hands of developers.
When and how unfortunately
we can't say yet.
But that is something that
we'd hopefully be able to
launch pretty soon.
I'm going to go over to Stack
Overflow real quick.
I mean, I look at the questions
in Stack Overflow
quite regularly.
And it looks like recently we
got a lot of questions on the
Google TV Emulator.
This potentially is related to
the fact that developers in
other countries are actually
using the Emulator for
development--
more even domestically
as well.
One question is, what are the
possibilities of the Google TV
Emulator primarily
around live TV?
So Google TV, and the Google TV
Emulator, actually supports
the listing and channel changing
APIs that the real
device supports.
But it doesn't, obviously, have
access to actually real
live TV content.
So what will happen when you set
up the Emulator, you enter
a US Postal code right now.
Once you give it the postal
code, you actually can figure
what content provider you have
or broadcast live TV provider.
And then actually the channel
lineup will be populated in
the channel listing provider.
So when you create a channel
listing provider you can get a
channel changing intent, and you
can actually fire off that
intent to change the channel.
What happens on the Emulator,
though, is that you're given a
test screen.
And it'll show you the call sign
for the channel and it'll
show you the number.
So you obviously don't have
access to actually the live
content, but we do emulate live
content in the Emulator.
So one other question we have,
this is actually a fairly
common question as well, about
using Anymote in the Emulator.
We actually don't
support Anymote
right now in the Emulator.
The issue is how we actually
bridge the network between the
Emulator and the platform.
This is something else
we're looking into.
Obviously I'm covering all the
questions that we get a lot.
If I keep saying that we're
looking into it, it's that
these are the questions that are
in the top of our queue.
Let me see.
One other question here--
actually I'm going to say
that's just about it.
We did have one more question
in Moderator about Google TV
being updated to ICS and how
long until Google TV is
updated to the next release.
This is something--
we don't necessarily announce
future releases, but we are
definitely looking into actually
updating it to a
future release.
Whether that's going to be ICS
or the release after that we
cannot say.
But it is something that
hopefully developers and users
can see in the not too
distant future.
So I think that's just about
it for the questions.
We started a little bit late,
but I'm going to say that I
think I covered kind of the main
questions that we had via
Moderator and Stack Overflow.
Again, so next week
the Google TV I/O
sessions are on Thursday.
I think they're starting
at 9:00 AM and
going through the morning.
We have one, Christian Kurzke
is going to give a talk on
media devices.
Ossama Alami is going to give
a talk on user experience.
And the talk that I'll be
giving is going to be on
building second screen apps that
integrate with Google TV.
Definitely hope to
see you there.
If you have any questions, feel
free to keep posting them
on Stack Overflow.
I'm guessing this moderator
queue will be open for a
little while.
So I can definitely respond
there as well.
And if you can make it to I/O,
I'd definitely like to meet up
with you there.